die Schweiz ist erlaubt
wir entscheiden mit eigentlich validiert
Wochenende
[Musik]
hier aber ja sehr geehrte und die ist
sie gern und dann aber
natürlich sauber
Fleisch aber
ich möchte absolute
machen zwischen
verschiedenen Reportage
Kategorien es gibt Nutztiere
persönliche Verbindung
[Musik]
angesprochen
das ist Gudrun
Doris Gerda und Frieda das sind lecker
das Huhn
übernähe das ist Luna sie ist von
reprivaten also von der Familie wo der
Fuchs
und ja hier sind sehr soziale Tiere
Strukturen und das [__] gefunden
komplett nackt sind also es ist
ausrangiert im Juni 2020
Gramm also wirklich riesig und ja und
das verstehe der Körper
pro Hund
völlig übertrieben und morgen genau so
solltet
jetzt
klassische Schweiz
es funktioniert
einfach jedes Huhn hat sich Charakter
viele sind sofort auseinanderhalten
jeder Mensch und ich Unterteil ist nicht
für mich sind einfach alles aber Wasser
einfach
sorry
gelandet und Gassen wurden interessiert
wäre
hey krasse Überblick wie die tabeader
machen also wenn sie da spar Katze
gerettet hat
die Menschen sagen
der ja irritiert
können
für Tierarzt Zürich vernetzt dir
der Katze Vergleich also das Tabea ihre
Hühner verstehe behandelt dass man
bliebe Katze sitzt perfekte dir wie ein
Thema
würde mich interessieren
[Musik]
fachkundiger Personen tötet werden das
muss nicht unbedingt der Metzger in sie
aber man muss schon wissen was man macht
also dir darf nicht Lieder und ja das
kontrolliere wegen
oder nicht ist natürlich nicht ganz
einfach
[Musik]
Katzenfleisch essen dann absolut absurd
und darum
mehrere Versuche
also dass man nimmt das hatte und
Hundefleisch Essen
mehrere Petitionen gehen
der Konsum von Haustieren in der Schweiz
ist dermaßen selten dass es unnötig ist
ein Verbot dafür in die Verfassung
aufzunehmen ja wirklich ziemlich lang
gesucht wo heute noch hat er ist und
wieder vor wird
das Video doch
ich finde das Thema
Katze vielleicht essen
[Musik]
Restaurant promotet
und jetzt
also YouTube
[Musik]
das Video rechts
AktivistInnen gemacht wurde und dem
Nachhinein gesagt es ist
irgendwie Plastik oder was
so wie immer
[Musik]
abstoßen sie aber gleichzeitig ähm
gemacht hat hat
ich Suche nach Antworten bringt mich
nach Langnau wie immer
von der Katze hat gefragt für die
audimente sehr klar er ist Ihre Frage
ist das Partner
hey Ross gern auf Dauer
Nutztier oder aus heimtierwort
dekorieren der hängt hier darf man
Medikamente aber man darf großflächig
Medikamente
Fleisch essen und Entwicklung Schweiz
ist klar es gibt hier also die Rossmann
Gewicht auf dem Bodengrund voll belaste
und jetzt ist seine Quali Lebensqualität
quasi beeinträchtigt die dem sind dass
er sich nicht mehr korrekt habe bewegen
und ähm kommen
das ist Manuela sie schaffen im
nationaler Pferdezentrum und könnte
darum so lang und die letzte zwei Jahre
Aktivität ich habe hier auf dem Hof
der Abschied vom trackmate macht ihr das
schaffen
also schwieriger
zu dem Ross
[Musik]
Wochenende
was Manuela mit dem Tier aufbaut hätte
das
und du vermerkte Haare Fragen die Worte
des wirklich sondern
Schlachtung von roscologen
perfekt passt zu dem Thema weil es dir
essen will es nicht was genau
ganz
ehrlich das muss ich mir nicht gern
wir treffen
uns treffen
[Applaus]
das ist nett dort vom Gesetz her ist es
nicht tot darum muss man
[Applaus]
die Schweiz wird Gang weniger rohes
fleischgasse
ja
die grössteil vom schweizgasse
importiert
es geht fehlurassen
da Metzger
bewusst sie nicht bleiben
versteht
wie Katzen Markus willt
spezieller vorlässige ist es immer sie
Hunde Dieter
der Titus hat Glück gehabt
dir so kategorisieren
oder Nutztier oder Schädling oder
Wildtier das ist immer relativ süß also
der Titus wohnt mit mir das ist ein
Freund oder ein Husten oder entfernt ist
Nutztier ja das brauchen wir zum
Schinken und der Schädling macht Felder
kaputt und das ist ja nicht natürlich
die unterteilig dass ich Kategorie wofür
ist die Zweck wichtig ist und wenn man
dann einfach lieb biologisch an der
Unterschied zwischen
Schweizer groß also beide sind
Intelligenz sozialkommunikativ
[Musik]
entscheidet über dir entscheide nutzen
wenn es Dir so hat über Generation wird
es ging so weiter
aber wenn ich mir vorstelle jetzt zum
Beispiel hat mir das ja einfach
hauptsächlich
oder natürlich mehr
Raubtiere
natürlich auch die sind ja die SMS und
Dir wo wieder von diesem Fernsehen
besser aber das ist aber kulturelle
Schweiz
Lieferanten das heißt das hat sich auch
verändert wie mir die gesehen und
ekliger sehr stark kulturell es gibt
biologische Ecke also gewisser Tier wie
er Schlangen oder so ja das ist ganze
durchgesetzt
andere Kultur oder Schlangen aber
delikatessen sind
das ist Ace zu erste beschrieb von mir
aus Verhalten gedankenlos schicken Wings
eine Fräser
züchtet sind dass sie auch kurzes Leben
dass sie zu Fleisch verarbeitet werden
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir aber
gern Fleisch das gehört und mit
probieren immer die zwei Sachen
miteinander kollidierung das zeigt sich
schon der Sprache ja dass wenn etwas
Zeit Lockerheit
und sobald man seine
körpergegangen machen und das ist
eigentlich recht gut im Seiten
kognitiven sondern zwei widersprechen
die einige hin Fleisch produziere
schlecht Fleisch essen gut
und wir probieren möglichst Stier beide
Seiten miteinander Berührung
[Gelächter]
meine Güte Geschenke
unangenehm wie mit der
Fleischkonsums beschäftigen
die Frage warum Essen
überhaupt hier
kognitive Dissonanz über Tierwohl noch
danke und Ines Roastbeef sandwichspieße
[Musik]
die schwarzen ist
also
das ist also Größe des kulturell bedingt
das ist vom Mittwoch geworden
50 bis 60 Jahre alt bleibt
eigentlich für effizienter und
ressourcenschonender Proteine
produzieren verglichen
kulturell bedingt weil Europa
es wird es umdenken
genau
fragen
und abonniert den Kanal
produziert Proteine